As an entrepreneur, when should I
start thinking about the Hook Model?
>> As early as possible.
Because the idea here is, well,
I'll tell you a personal story.
So I've been at two companies.
One of my,
at the last startup that I helped found,
one of the problems we constantly
had was what do we build?
So, we were big believers in the lean
start methodology of build, measure,
learn, customer development,
big believers in that.
Still am.
But we always had this challenge
of what do we build next, right?
This is where all the blood,
sweat, and tears and money all go,
it's the building.
Testing and learning, measuring and
learning, that's easy, that's fun.
>> Right.
>> It's the building that's hard.
So the question we constantly,
constantly had was,
you know what do we build next?
Do we build what the VCs
say we should build?
Do we build what the loudest
customer say what we should build?
Do we build what people who write into
customer support say we should build?
What do we build?
And so, what I, what I propose is that
instead of just guessing, or you know,
taking a shot at, or dot voting,
even, based on what the team thinks
we need some kind of framework based on
how people actually behave because it
turns out that just asking people what
they want is not a really great measure.
Because people can only
articulate certain things.
There's all these inarticulatable
needs that drive our behavior and
people couldn't tell you
actually drive their behavior.
>> Right.
>> So instead of just guessing we need
consumer psychology to help us
build the right things sooner.
We still have to do build,
measure, learn.
We're still going to mess up,
we're not going to build perfect
products the first time.
The idea is that we can
build the right thing sooner
by basing what we build on
the foundations of consumer psychology.